there's no conceivable connect scenario
which would have been plausible to say
why I was this Chinese kid being brought
up by white folks it was a thing that
was used as a negative more so than a
positive
okay how old were you when you found out
you were adopted I used to get read a
bedtime story and to try and introduce
the idea to me quite early it was kind
of like the day in the life of a normal
child and then it just said but I'm
special because I'm adopted
and did that click quite early on in a
way it made it sort of a bit more of a
better thing because I was kind of
special and chosen what about yourself
me it was a bit more dramatic 3 4 my
adoptive mother was a primary school
teacher so I got hauled in to school as
a bring intel object and stood on a desk
and presented to the other kids about 30
of them and that was how you found out
Wow I mean I had kids coming up to me
kinda like um licking their fingers to
see if the yellow will come off Wow but
that was you know you're talking 50 60
so you know that's the way people
thought it's your birthday your birthday
no oh is it no the day that my birthday
is the day that I was registered at the
orphanage I've never heard of that
before never heard of that before what
about you yet my birthday is my birthday
what is your relationship to your
biological parents so I have actually
traced them and it's fantastic
birth mother my auntie's my
half-brothers the three of them have all
got absolutely brilliant relationships
now so if anything I kind of wished I'd
done the whole tracing process a little
sooner because it doesn't always work
out it doesn't know and I know that I
was lucky
have you traced your birth family I did
recently take part in oh the one with
Davina yeah yeah they did a special on
foundlings so I do actually have some
living fourth and fifth cousins when I
get some time I might kind of
how far I can take that see if they know
anything about their extended family and
and how we actually fit in did you keep
your adoption a secret no I don't think
so certainly in my early years it was
kind of like a distinguishing feature of
Mille and actually it was something that
I kind of wore quite proudly it was only
really when I was in my teenage years
when sort of I was trying to unpick it
and kind of understand and filter out
some of the anxieties around I suppose
as an adoptive person quite often you
can feel unwanted unloved and you know
that kind of element I couldn't really
hide it so I mean it was something that
was always there because I wasn't I
wasn't white and there's no conceivable
connect scenario which would have been
plausible to say why I was this Chinese
kid being brought up by white folks kind
of taken out of my hands and it was a
thing that was used as a negative then
more so than a positive how has adoption
affected your love life I think in the
early days it did affect my ability to
be trustful in relationships so I always
used to get obsessed with the the term
unconditional love I do think that I
have certainly earlier in life struggled
to connect with people and I think it
all boils down to this idea that in some
way I was excluded from the normal
notion of love and yet I've got to where
I am now and I've realized that that was
all just silly and self and self imposed
what I would say which some people might
say is controversial I think you did
experience unconditional love from your
birth mother because she did what she
did and that's incredibly hard I cannot
even begin to imagine the circumstances
that would drive a mother to like me to
abandon me somewhere in a place where
she knew that I would be picked up it's
called abandoned in order to be found
that's what they called it
similarly with your mother knowing that
she wanted you to
in life and if you flip that and say
your mother could have been selfish and
she could have held on to you and that
could have taken you down completely
different route the same with my my my
birth mother could have been selfish did
your feelings about being adopted change
as you got older yes because when I was
very young it was a positive thing but
then sort of in my teenage years it
became profoundly negative during that
time and it was mixed with other things
about the fact that I'm gay then when I
done the whole tracing process and I'd
understood sort of where I'd come from
and then it became positive again but I
think the defining point was that I'd
stop looking backwards it's something I
couldn't define and then was able just
to start looking forward for me because
it started off very much as a negative
thing I mean they never once actually
sat me down and had the conversation do
you realise you you were adopted they
never told me that and I say that I can
laugh about that now I mean how long did
they think that I wouldn't notice you
know it's the elephant in the room isn't
it and then I went back to Hong Kong for
the first time and for the first time I
was able to walk down the streets and
actually not be the odd one out and
actually look across and see everybody
just me reflected back in various
different guises it was weirdest a
wonderful thing but incredibly weird and
I realized at that point that I spent
most of my time when I'm here when I was
here walking around with my heads
pointed down so that people wouldn't
notice I think I sort of subliminally or
subconsciously got to the point where I
had to I'll accept what I was and try
and make my own peace with that what was
one negative experience of adoption each
translational doctor each adoptee has
their own their own story and
it's one of the things that I say to
people who do have I think ask you
whiffed idea that adoption is always
going to be a transformative experience
is always going to be a fairy tale it's
not because you're dealing with human
beings the most negative thing about the
adoption when I'm was adopted was the
prescriptive idea that you know so if
it's a clean break you don't acknowledge
what's happened to the child the world
that that child may have come from the
only way that you can you can deal with
it is by basically cutting off all links
which is complete nonsense I think for
me it was quite a large amount of time
where I was left just to kind of make up
my own story
instead of actually just being reassured
and I know from my work with adoption
agencies now that that there is a lot
more support would you adopt yes
absolutely yes what I adopt no I
wouldn't
from my point of view is that I would
want to have adopted somebody that was
obese days in East Asian heritage so it
would have meant me going back to
mainland China that having been done to
me and I didn't particularly like it and
the challenges that that created for me
I wouldn't necessarily want to give
those to another child what would have
been quite nice when I was growing up
and I had my brother he was also adopted
as well but it would have been quite
nice to have had a little more adult
understanding to help to coach me
through that journey and I can't wait to
do that and really genuinely can't wait
to do that yeah thank you very much
and you
you